if it doesn't really look like the hair
and a bear coming their brains out
then it won't read on TV hi I'm Marcy
Kramer and my job at Conan is to make a
sculpture of a heron having sex with a
bear every day just a case of Sketch
balls for that every morning at 9:00
a.m. we have a department meeting where
we get our assignments thank you very
much sir
Marcy I'm gonna need you to make a paper
mache sculpture of a great hair and
making love to a grizzly bear Marcy I
tell you this every day we don't need
that script is never called for it well
we might goddamn need it today Craig did
you think about that did you think about
that my coworkers are nice people but
they lack vision it's like soccer great
Pele sin don't go to where the ball is
go to where the ball will be but instead
of soccer it's a sculpture of a bird
deep [ __ ] a bear that's not what I
told you to make you know what I asked
you to make I'm making it do what I
asked you to do all right yeah you're
the boss I'm really good at reading
people I find that when people say Marcy
please don't make that sculpture ever
burn a bear [ __ ] they really mean is
Marcy you know best make that sculpture
so every morning I wake up and I make my
sculpture so I can prevent this show
being ruined because no one made a
replica of a hair on having sex with a
bear again so but or mouse the most
tense part of my day is an hour before
show time because that's when our head
writer comes in and reviews all of our
work I tell you every single day we
don't need that you don't have a sketch
like Nicole Kidman's like interspecies
mating zoo no like as a closer bit and
the worst but mitzvah themes
time stop making this [ __ ] okay you
don't want it you don't want it you
don't want it I'm not firing her because
the day she started working here she
gave me a photo of me and my family
eating dinner she burned the faces off
with a match and then she rolled on top
kill family if
job go away and then on the back she
wrote to hell sometimes I lose my
composure a little when my sculptures in
use the next day I'm all smiles and
right back at it
Marcy will need the tape let me show you
sculpture of a great here on pluggin
agree flee where Marcy for the last time
we don't need that